it okay okay scary surprise can you
reveal your identity big moment
[Laughter]
I'm quite a relief actually well done
yeah well played yeah thanks well yeah
um
I'm never talking to you again
[Laughter]
I think the entire like the entire
viewership of this show is now forever
traumatized and yeah
no I mean first of all like I didn't
mean to really prevent people from from
playing well or something but actually
when we when we started I think it was
like three am in place
and where I uh where I currently live so
I I was like I was about to fall asleep
somehow
and yeah I mean I uh first of all it's
fun but secondly I also I mean I really
felt like I desperately need some
Fitness to like at least you know
survives the rest and all the stuff like
when I had this break I was I mean again
I went to to bed I was again like about
to fall asleep but yes okay I managed to
so this is my self-care this was done
this was done not to fall asleep
it was a bit of everything but also I
think it's it's kind of fun no